Vamos a resolver la desigualdad, el valor
absoluto de "2r" menos 3 enteros 1/4,
esto tiene que ser menor que 2 enteros 1/2.
Y bueno, de hecho antes de meterme a resolver
esta desigualdad con valor absoluto, quiero
recordar un poco lo que veíamos en el video pasado.
Si yo tenía que el valor absoluto de "x" era
menor que 2 enteros 1/2,
vamos a tomarnos lo mismo, ¿qué quería decir esto?
¡Ah! bueno, que "x" tenía que ser menor
que 2 enteros 1/2...
"x" tiene que ser menor que 2 1/2 y a su vez,
"x" tiene que ser mayor que -2 enteros 1/2...
tiene que ser mayor que -2 enteros 1/2.
Ambas desigualdades se tienen que cumplir
simultáneamente y si esto lo veíamos en
una recta numérica y aquí estaba el 0,
aquí estaba el 2 enteros 1/2 y por aquí el -2 enteros 1/2, si yo me fijo en la distancia
que hay del 0 al 2 enteros 1/2 y al -2 enteros
1/2, pues vamos a ver que hay dos unidades
y media de distancia al 0 y si yo lo que quiero
es buscar los números que cumplan que su
distancia sea menor que 2 enteros 1/2, pues
tienen que ser aquellos números que están
entre estos dos valores, es decir, todos estos.
La distancia de este número al 0,
tiene que ser menor que 2 enteros 1/2, por lo tanto tiene que ser todo esto que estoy pintando de azul.
Justo esto era lo que habíamos visto
hace algunos videos
y más aun, si nosotros teníamos que el valor absoluto de "x" era mayor que 2 enteros 1/2,
lo que nos resultaba de solución era justo lo contrario, los intervalos que eran más grandes que 2 enteros 1/2
o en su dado caso más chicos
que -2 enteros 1/2, pero bueno,
regresemos a este problema original.
Yo lo que quiero es que esto, esto que está
adentro de mi valor absoluto, va a servir
igual que "x", es decir, lo que quiero es
que "2r" menos 3 enteros 1/4
sea menor que 2 enteros 1/2 ...
que 2 enteros 1/2 y a su vez, simultáneamente,
se cumpla que "2r" menos 3 enteros 1/4
sea más grande que -2 enteros 1/2 .
Estoy utilizando exactamente la misma lógica
que utilicé aquí a la derecha, es más déjame
hacer una línea para que no nos confundamos.
Esto, que está adentro de mi valor absoluto,
es justo a lo que yo me refería con la "x"
aquí del lado derecho, y bueno, si ya tengo
estas dos desigualdades, lo único que hay
que hacer es resolverlas para "r".
Y por lo tanto, lo único que hay que hacer
es despejar a "r", pero si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos fracciones, así que lo primero que
voy a hacer es pasar estas fracciones de mixtas
a impropias y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es multiplicar 4 por 3 = 12 más 1, lo bueno
es que lo que haga de un lado, también me
va a servir del otro lado o al menos en un
principio y entonces mejor voy a escribir
esto como "2r" menos 4 por 3 = 12 más 1 = 13,
son 13/4, entonces me va a quedar "2r" menos
13/4, esto tiene que ser menor o igual...
espera, cuartos, no tercios...
no me vaya yo a confundir por una cosita así.
Esto tiene que ser menor que 2 por 2 = 4 más
1 = 5, es decir, 5/2, bueno, esto por una
parte, pero por otra parte, también tenemos
que "2r" menos 3 enteros 1/4 tiene que ser
mayor que -2 enteros 1/2, pero bueno,
esto es lo mismo que "2r" menos 13/4 tiene que
ser mayor que -5/2.
Muy bien, pero como no es lo mejor trabajar
con fracciones, a mi lo que se me ocurre es,
multiplicar toda esta desigualdad por 4, como
el 4 es un número positivo,
se mantiene la desigualdad y entonces vamos a multiplicar todo esto por 4, ¿y qué me va a quedar?
4 por "2r" es "8r", 4 que multiplica a -13/4,
pues el 4 y el 4 se van y me queda -13
y después date cuenta que la desigualdad se mantiene
igual porque el 4 es un número positivo
y después me queda, 4 entre 2 es 2, 2 por 5 = 10, entonces "8r" menos 13, tiene que ser menor que 10,
porque 2 por 5 es 10.
Bueno, primero déjenme resolver esta
desigualdad del lado izquierdo
y ya después me voy a
ir con la desigualdad del lado derecho.
De aquí si lo que quiero es despejar a "r",
lo primero que voy a hacer es sumar a 13 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me queda que
"8r" tiene que ser menor, estos dos se van,
que 10 más 13, que es 23.
Y bueno, si divido ambos lados de esta desigualdad
entre 8 y como 8 es un número positivo se
conserva la desigualdad, me queda que 8 y 8 se van,
la desigualdad se mantiene igual y entonces me queda que "r" tiene que ser menor que 23/8...
"r" tiene que ser menor que 23/8...
¡Perfecto! ya aquí tengo mi solución de
mi primera desigualdad, "r" menor que 23/8
ó esto si lo vemos como fracción mixta es
2 enteros 7/8, 8 por 12 = 16 más 7 = 23.
Bueno, pero ésta en una primera parte, en una primera desigualdad, porque también tengo otra desigualdad,
dice, se tiene que cumplir la primera desigualdad y la segunda desigualdad que es ésta que tengo aquí.
Pero de igual manera tengo fracciones, por
lo tanto lo primero que voy a hacer es multiplicar
ambos lados de esa desigualdad por 4, otra
vez, como el 4 es un número positivo,
no se afecta la desigualdad y me queda, "8r"
menos 13 tiene que ser mayor que 4 entre 2
es 2 por 5 es 10, -10.
"8r" menos 13 tiene que ser mayor que -10
y sumando 13 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
me va a quedar que "8r", 13 menos 13 se van,
"8r" tiene que ser mayor que -10 más 13 que es 3.
"8r" tiene que ser mayor que 3.
Y bueno, yo lo que quiero es despejar a "r"
de esta desigualdad, por lo tanto voy a dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 8,
como 8 es un número positivo no se afecta esta
desigualdad, me queda que "r" es mayor que 3/8.
Y a 3/8 no le podemos sacar enteros, por lo tanto es una fracción propia. Y ¡Perfecto!
Ya tenemos entonces mis dos condiciones que
tiene que cumplir "r" y por lo tanto mi intervalo
en el cual vive "r".
"r" por una parte tiene que ser mayor que 3/8,
para que cumpla esta desigualdad con
valor absoluto, "r" tiene que ser mayor que
3/8 y por otra parte tiene que ser menor que
2 enteros 7/8.
Así que, pues lo único que nos falta es ponerlo
en esta recta numérica
y vamos a ver que tal nos queda.
0, por aquí va a estar el 1,
por aquí va a estar el 2 y por aquí vamos a tener al 3.
Y yo lo que quiero es que "r" sea en primer
lugar, más chico que 2 enteros 7/8....
2 enteros 7/8 está por aquí...
y después que sea más grande que 3/8,
voy a decir que 3/8 está por aquí y bueno como
son desigualdades estrictas entonces no toca 3/8,
no toca 2 enteros 7/8 y todo lo que viva
aquí en medio de estos dos, va a ser mi solución.
Y bueno, sería bastante útil probar que
realmente sí es esta solución.
Si yo me tomo un número, aquí entre estos
2, supongamos 1, vamos a ver qué me queda
con esta desigualdad, 2 por 1 porque "r" vale
1 menos 3 enteros 1/4, 2 menos 3 enteros 1/4
y esto es lo mismo que 3 enteros 1/4 menos 2
es 1 entero 1/4 por menos, me queda -1 entero 1/4,
pero ojo, me estoy tomando el valor absoluto...
el valor absoluto de esto...
y esto es igual a 1 entero 1/4, que por cierto
es mucho más pequeño que 2 enteros 1/2
y ¿qué pasa si me tomo un valor que este fuera
de este intervalo?
¿Será que me equivoqué y tal vez si esté
en esta solución?
Pues vamos a ver, si "r" vale 0 me queda 2 por 0 = 0, menos 3 enteros 1/4...
el valor absoluto de -3 enteros 1/4 es 3 enteros
1/4 y lamentablemente no es parte de mi solución
porque esto es más grande que 2 enteros 1/2.
Y supongamos que me tomo ahora 3,
vamos a ver si con el 3 funciona.
2 por 3 es 6, 6 menos 3 enteros 1/4 es 2 enteros 3/4...
2 enteros 3/4, lo cual cuando me tomo el
valor absoluto es 2 enteros 3/4,
que es mayor que 2 enteros 1/2, es una lástima, porque por lo tanto no está en nuestra solución.